I recently got the chance to meet one of
the top polo players in the world nacho
figueras what a cool name yeah nacho
figueras
and I don't know much about polo so I
asked nacho if he could take me out to a
polo ground show me you know a little
bit about the game what it's about how
it works I brought a camera crew along
we had some fun I think I learned a lot
here's what happened hi I'm standing
next to one of the world's greatest polo
players
nacho if you get us not show how are you
I'm very nice nice to meet you nacho is
not only a great polo player from
Argentina you are also a Ralph Lauren
model that's what they say yes I applied
for that job yeah what happened there
here nothing nothing no callback nothing
they told me that it was no offence but
they said it was because of my face and
my body thank you well you're a very
attractive man I am not attracted to
most men I am very attracted to you but
in a way that is acceptable I believe no
no no in a way that is okay in that good
way ok thank you
[Laughter]
I would like to master polo in 20 to 40
minutes is this possible I think we
couldn't do it yes ok I'm excited and I
think this is gonna be an incredible
bird it's chirping in the background I
don't know if you can hear that if I
knew what the birds natural predator was
I would make that sound and frighten it
away but I have alright so these are the
horses these are beautiful horses these
are very powerful animals these horses
what horse are you using is this your
animal this one's mine and that's ones
for you yeah ok your horse obviously
more handsome than my horse of course
yes alright tell us what is the name of
your horse name of my horse is Dante
Dante yeah what a strong powerful name
and what is the name of my horse the
name of your horse is fat Tina
Tina yeah okay yeah well you know you
and we wanted to Jude see they're
already getting ready for us why this is
there that's scary it's like Jurassic
Park the next step would be the suit up
we must dress appropriately
solutely not sure and I are gonna go
change ladies prepare yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a polo mallet this is what we're
going to hit the ball with you're gonna
hit it with this part not with this part
if you see the number 52 here that's the
how long the model is 52 inches against
yours is 53 yes Ryan your longer perfect
Hey your legs are pretty long oh it's
like very long legs yeah yeah I have
very long legs in a tiny torso
basketball player legs yes and then the
torso of yeah fetus yeah
helmet it will ruin your hair here's the
thing I want to look cool that's more
important to me than safety so let's
yeah take a look at the helmet and see
how how does it look how does it look
yeah yeah no I would I would rather be
killed now my Boris we talked about this
earlier could we give the horse the
weekend we gave the horse that night put
on red Mike will has been given two
buckets of Apple nyquil great and the
source also may be watched a long dull
movie yes no we have him watch the few
episodes of your show and so the horses
are sleepy as they can be yeah now how
do I make sure I don't hit the horse we
need to do that you you won't the the
key thing is for you to rotate your
upper body a little your little torso
little top rotate a little bit this is
the near side shot
that's a nearside nearside shot where
you cross over also you have might
rotate your little torso maybe a little
something 1/4 so yeah I'd say I'm small
short what do you think the offensive
plays very important riding off right
we'll come on boom and I move you out of
the ball out of alignment and take you
out of the play am I allowed to use my
mallet to try and smash your face
no can I
your hair can I shrink and pull it your
hair there you go
okay so KY my horse just said that's not
how you do it
my horse just said no I'm trying to look
handsome that's something I should be
focused on yes
muuu for you need to make an effort oh
[Laughter]
my horse won't go that fast
divorce is depressed about the economy
oh sorry whoa okay it didn't work
oh shoot come on one more chance you'll
be tired to where your legs are gonna be
sore I need oxygen I need new skin for
my thighs I need a skin graft and I
steal it from you here right ah oh don't
get it come get it attack go back Tina
fly like the wind no back Tina please
I'll take you to Applebee's just yes yes
here we go buddy it is quite good for
the first time so it's been a terrific
day all around but nacho thank you very
much you're a class act and I thank you
it was thought it was great now I attack
you you let your guard down you ever do
that they are never do that don't do
that either
[Applause]
you